Nếu như các bạn pháp trường pháp mới của Mỹ nhạm vào lĩnh vực năng lực,
nhà nhà hàng nhà bà thống người kèng báo,
đồng thế này có thể làm suy yếu nỗ lực ngoại giao nhằm chấm rất xung độ của quay nè.
Nguy phân ngôn bộ ngoại giao ngàn bà biệt chật khá rốt và thật định.
Mà sức và đã phát triển khả năng chống trưởng đáng kể sau nhiều năm trước xứ kế,
từ đáng giọng hoá thì trường xúc không năng lực.
Đến thúc đẩy thành thoảng măng đồng đội tệ,
theo ngà rất lành trường phát tri kến quan hệ xong phương thêm phần căng thần.
Để các bên xác dự bản nằm phán,
chúng của cùng ngày cũng phản đối tất cả lệnh trường phản đối phương,
nhưng mạnh đối thoại mới là con đường khả thị để xa khuy khủng hăng.
Châu khi đó, Mỹ và EU tìm tổng ngờ giọng xanh xanh trường phán,
nhằm bà các tập đoạn năng lượng lượng lượng như Rosnaf,
lúc ai và lĩnh vực khi hóa lòng của ngà theo dưới phần tiết,
để các bên già tàn xức xong hành với phân ngôn cứng sẵn,
cho thấy chiến pháp đối thoại dựa các bên liên quan vẫn còn nhiều thế thức.